[MUSIC PLAYING]
This episode of "Shots
of Awe" is brought you
by the Toyota Prius.
Let's lead the way.
Kevin Kelly used to say
humans are the sex organs
of technology.
And what he meant by that was
that technology was a living
organism that was
using us to extend
its reproductive capacity,
similar to the way
those pollen flowers use bees
in order to spread their seeds.
The history of
technology highlights
what's known as bootstrapping.
Essentially, we
use one technology
to build the next technology.
And then we use
the next technology
to build the next technology,
and so on and so forth,
until what we have
is a telescoping
nature of evolutionary change
in which the nature of change
itself changes.
And so what we have really
to define the human story
is what's known as
transforming and transcending.
We use these
technological scaffolding
to build new
capabilities, bring them
into our cognitive
arsenal, and then create
new possibility
spaces for ourselves.
Probing the adjacent
possible, we remix what is.
And we create virtual
models, and we
actualize those new virtual
models into existence.
Essentially, our
mastery of technology
has given us new construction
kits for our reality.
And I love this idea.
Eric Davis said it best.
The human design
process will achieve
a kind of infinite velocity,
where everything becomes
linked with everything else.
And matter becomes mind.